from addiction to a devastating medical
diagnose shelly keller grew up with a
lot of obstacles
but she's a shining example of how the
biggest challenges can become
opportunities to create your own life
and the lives of others
she's inspired countless students to
achieve their dreams and as alex backus
shows us that's just one reason she was
selected as a remarkable woman
dr shelly keller has spent 15 years at
the college of southern nevada
it's a place she never imagined she
could be
i walked into that campus and it changed
my life
shelly was born in ohio she experienced
trauma as a child
and remembers having her first drink at
six years old
just a sip you know when i tasted it i
immediately
thought oh this this helps me feel
better by the time she was 13
shelley was drinking heavily she was
also having major stomach issues
had surgery then received devastating
news
they're telling me i can't have children
and that devastated me
shelley dropped out of high school
continued drinking and became
addicted to meth for 15 years that was
the hardest thing i ever did
was to stop drinking i
i went to that rehab but that wasn't the
first rehab i went to
she kept fighting in 2006 shelley was
figuring out her next steps
and a counselor asked if she thought
about community college
shelley walked onto the csn campus and
with guidance
and encouragement enrolled as a student
it gave me hope
it gave me self-worth it connected me to
people that
lived different ways shelley went on to
unlv where she's earned a phd
she is the first in her family to
graduate college
but shelley wanted to return to csn she
was hired as a public speaking professor
she is now the director for the centers
for academic success
her job is helping students achieve
their dreams
it's the most remarkable experience to
tell you the truth is to
be giving back barbara iarza's dream was
college
at 40 years old a single mom of six and
a high school dropout
her dream seemed out of reach been
through about the worst of the worst
so homeless at a woman's shelter
lost both my parents she went to student
orientation at csn
and met dr shelly keller her first day
basically just
bawled my eyes out and told her my story
and how desperate i was
and having no idea that she was the
perfect person
in the perfect position shelly helped
barbara with a job
child care and most importantly
encouragement
barbara since landed a full ride to unlv
where she's earned a bachelor's
in psychology she's just really
everything to me
she really is because i would never hate
it
thousands of students that can tell you
that how she's touched their lives
while she succeeded professionally
shelley still dreamt of having her own
family
she and her husband became foster
parents and 14 years ago
they adopted their two children emma and
joseph
both were impacted by drugs and alcohol
and i knew
that i would have something to offer
those kids
they are the best kids they're just
they're remarkable
if you went back to being 13
and could see you right now
would you ever believe that that
question will make me cry
because no no i was so
uh i had lost hope
as a child shelly has been sober since
2010
and her mission to help others is far
from over some of the hardest things you
go through
in the end you see so much meaning if
you just look for it
alex backus 8 news now
shelley credits counseling for helping
her turn her life around
and she returned to school to become a
counselor herself christian well she
also started a non-profit the nevada
institute for mental health
and addiction great story